so thanksgiving is around the corner
folks if you live in new york and
california
we have to warn you you have to do
thanksgiving right if you live in new
york and california so you cannot screw
this thing up because people are going
to come to your house
and some bad things could happen kai do
you want to pull up what the guidelines
are
uh for uh do you have both new york and
california
okay so you want me to read all of this
i needed like a basic one-pager so
here's
here's huh i i'm i'm still trying to
find it buddy i'm telling you the point
is there's a lot of freaking rules over
here
okay so ladies and gentlemen that's
kailu over there all right here we go
here we go so this is california is this
new york guy the first one you're giving
me
okay california three household max
limit
must gather outdoors social distancing
must take place
you must wear masks between bites and
drinking
less than two hours no singing or
shouting
this is your thanksgiving in california
let me read this one more time by the
way this is from their website this is
not a joke
when i saw this i said it's for sure a
joke let me read this again
are you guys hearing this i'm
flabbergasted by this
so you can have a maximum three
household maximum limit
okay must gather that includes your
house limits you can only have two get
two house loans so you bring your mom
dad
kids that's it two more i can have two
more of those
must gather outdoors not indoors social
distancing
must take place you must wear masks
in between bites and drinking less than
two hours is what you can spend time
with your family look at the look on
your face
no singing or shouting what do you mean
no
singing or shouting can you control f to
see if that is bs that it says no right
there
rules were singing chanting shouting
outdoor gatherings sending channing
shouting and physical exertion
significantly
increases the risk of cocktail
transmission
because these activities increase the
release of respiratory droplets
and fine aerosols into the air because
of this singing chanting and shouting
are strongly discouraged but if they all
occur
the following rules and recommendations
apply all people who are singing or
chanting should wear a mask
covering at all times while singing or
chan including anyone who is leading a
song or chant
hence they're talking about the church
because these activities pose a very
high risk of covet 19 transmission phase
what coverings
are essential to reduce the spread of
respiratory droplets and air so i mean
this has got to be pathetic right
by the way that's california so let me
get your reaction for some california go
ahead okay by the way playing of wind
instruments is strongly discouraged
okay go back to case you're you're you
know a mad uh jazz flute
aficionado um
you know listen this is funny to a point
but these are
actual elected officials who spent a
great
deal of time on this i'm petrified for
the future of california
and new york and i am not joking these
people will
subtly like little surgeons little
psycho surgeons is all they are
one step at a time normalize it oh we're
not going to let you sing
oh you know take a bite of stuffing put
your mass back on
chew quietly don't sing don't go to
church these guys are serious
about jacking all our freedoms and
that's not a conspiracy theory if they
went through that much time
to write in that great of detail they're
sick
people there's something wrong with that
i mean it's so
anti-american on every single level and
it speaks to
fear and it speaks to panic and it
speaks to
we know what's best for you let us
protect you every second of the day
these are your people tom in california
these are your people how do you live
there how do you i don't
know i don't know you live there for how
long six years
when are you getting out of there man
enough's enough it's it's
it's unbelievable it truly is
unbelievable the other day no i'm
serious
i'm being serious like when is enough
enough that you're gonna leave well i
think we've hit that point
so you're out well look i'm not here to
make any big announcements but i mean
how much more can you take i mean i
can't take anymore um
the other day i mean you guys saw this
that one city council member in los
angeles wants to turn the la convention
center
right next to the staples center into a
homeless shelter
by the way there's no showers there's
limited bathrooms um when there's no can
by the way
every day at the convention center is
booked for the next five years
how are you just going to truck all the
homeless could you imagine what they
would do to the convention center
it would be destroyed it would be done
garcetti says
i need a little bit more data on this
but i think for the time being we'll
keep them in four-star hotels
you know because they do take over
hotels and just move them right in
sick you know it's unbelievable same
thing in new york moving to california
why would you want to leave california
you get a free hotel
yeah these uh these things are obviously
a freaking joke
these rules this is not a but i wish it
was a joke i get that i get that
the the the fact that they're trying to
enforce these rules are the joke
i look at this two different ways number
one who's actually going to follow this
ah this
birthday no no singing on my birthday
some people will there are californians
at will
i look at this as not about who's gonna
follow that's not the point who's gonna
follow it yeah i look at this as
they have to put something out right
like they can't just
be blind to the fact now how are they
gonna enforce this are the
you know thanksgiving police gonna be
knocking down your door like the gestapo
being like whoa how many households we
got here did i see someone singing oh
take that stuffing out of your mouth put
a mask on i don't think they're gonna
how
tell me how they're gonna enforce this i
don't think that's even a possibility
the way i look at it is they're probably
saying we gotta do something we gotta
say
something this is a super extreme i
agree but they can't just be
here be careful be smart that is the
mistake
be careful but in you know government
legislative terms they
it's it's absurd no doubt so however
they need to say something
uh tucker carlson was on with adam kroll
and they said if the police show up just
say you're staging a rally and that's
perfectly fine
you're peacefully protesting in the
backyard you're peacefully protesting
as if it's 20 degrees in new york on
thanksgiving you got to be outside
that's california what you just saw
right there is california they're
talking about california specifically
i'm going to give you
your guidelines right now and that was
just but that's all you think about
that's all you think about you you just
think about that's that's it
no i gave you two sides of the coin
there that it's absurd but they have to
say something let me tell you what's
what is absurd if they enforce this
right now you just want to put a
guideline fine
if you enforce this and there's video
footage game over
you're going to see some crazy stuff
happen in california if they enforce it
i pray that they're bright enough
and have enough social intelligence
eq emotional intelligence to not go and
force us because if they do
right the amount of fire they're gonna
get from people from this
is going to be absolute insane in the
state of california totally agree
here's what cuomo said my personal
advice is the best way to say i love you
this thanksgiving the best way to say
i'm thankful for you is to say
i love you so much i'm thankful for you
that i don't want to endanger you and i
want i don't want to endanger
our family and i don't want to end the
engine endanger our friends so we'll
celebrate
virtually he added but this is my
personal opinion which is fine he can
have an opinion
almost because cuomo's speaking deck the
guy that decks people on the show listen
this is tight that people on the
shoulder that's that guy
if you travel to one of the 41 states or
territories
on new york's travel advisory you will
need to quarantine for two weeks when
you return
however the governor added you can go
where you want
as the travel advisory is not a ban
and their current guidelines that they
gave
10 people curfew 10 p.m curfew for all
bars restaurants gyms and liquor stores
10 p.m curfew curbside pickup or
delivery okay no alcohol to go
indoor and outdoor gatherings at private
residences
limited to 10 people so new york's given
a specific number it's 10 people
california is saying three households
including yours which they're really
saying 12 people yeah you got four times
three so that's new york what do you
think about that i think newsom
is seriously he has mental issues i mean
the level of detail that was on that
california list
the new york list was a little bit more
practical i mean it had some level of
sanity
built into it what's the point of i mean
at least their gyms are open
at least gyms are open in new york
they're not even opening california at
least they can stay at a gym until 10
o'clock or go to a bar till 10 o'clock
we can't even do that in california
you talk about uh uh enforcing the laws
manhattan beach
there's every weekend the yellow
windbreakers are out on every street
corner in downtown if you don't have
your mask
up over your nose they've got clipboards
they're yelling at you
they are moderately enforcing now
there's no way you can go into people's
homes
i mean there might be a stand your
ground situation if they try to do that
but it just the the thing that really
kills me is each week there's something
new
and they keep talking about covet cases
and and all i can say is i have a
different mentality when it comes to it
i believe that we need to do whatever we
can to protect the people that are most
vulnerable
but everybody else just be smart and
have some common sense
my wife's entire family tested positive
for covet and they're all fine
they all were ready to go after a couple
two or three days they live in missouri
don't worry
um you know and then you hear about all
these athletes you know that test
positive in their back plane
in a week or less than that so the
hysteria has gotten so out of control
now they're using the holiday wait till
christmas rules come out
i mean agree this is absurd i don't
think there's any way that they can
enforce it i
totally agree that it's laughable it's
laughable it's laughable
but let's just look at some of the other
stuff that's out there i get it
uh 10 million covered cases we've just
crossed 10 million in the united states
these are facts um really proud to say
here in texas we are leading the way
here baby one million cases
crossing texas we're number one if you
ain't first your last way to go texas
um the the whole protecting people
um yes i think we can all agree young
healthy vibrant people are not the ones
that are at risk
but the concern is you show up you want
to give grandma a kiss
it's uh thanksgiving you start singing
uh la la says
boom grandma dies that's what people are
concerned about
yeah i mean that's a thanksgiving song
around my house you know
point is it's not so much the young
people the kilties of the world
this crew over here but they show up
they come home for thanksgiving they see
their family
they give grandma kiss now you're going
to grandma's funeral
that's the concern is that immediate
kiss death burial i mean move on yeah i
mean not immediate but i mean
are we we're going to play the game that
old people aren't dying but we're going
to play that game right now
no not playing that game at all but why
can't we determine
whether a grammar should come over just
or not why do we want to kill your
grandma
tom go ahead i'm just letting you know
that's the concern
like as much as i think that these rules
are a freaking joke and there's no way
to enforce them
and it is absurd and it's laughable
we're having a nice chuckle about it i
get it
covets real 10 million cases million in
texas where we are
and they're they need to have some sort
of guidelines by the way
let me tell you one thing let me tell
you one thing about when you say texas
has the most cases
i called ricky and i said ricky go get
your covet test you and your wife
no okay i call ricky ricky says let me
find one
i said dude let me just tell you where
we go there's one pretty much there's
15 places within a five mile radius here
i can go take the cove test
he calls her and says pat there's a nun
so what are you talking about he says
there's none
i said ricky go find i'm getting upset
at this point i'd recommend ricky you
i'm thinking he's not being resourceful
he just kind of doesn't want to go take
it
he says pam i'm telling you there is no
that's a ricky find a place
there's got to be one do you know ricky
and his wife had to drive
three hours to the closest place to get
kova tested
i believe it in california bakersfield
in california yes
i thought you mentioned but the point is
california hasn't made it as easy to
take tests as texas has
texas is made so easy so you want to go
get the bro over here
every time yesterday one of our guys
their kids in school
something happened one kid had a
temperature 101
you know what i'm talking about okay he
had 101 degree temperature kid was at
103.5 this morning he's doing better now
but uh they took her right off the bat
to get the kid tested you know how long
of a drive it was for her
five minutes one got tested negative
came back home california they don't
have them everywhere
so as much as people say texas is
leading the way
yeah texas has also made it accessible
not all
states have made it as accessible as
easy to go take the test
as texas as texas has no problem you go
in and take into custody for you but
they go out and say oh cases
cases yeah because texas has done a
phenomenal nobody gives the credit
to say great job to texas for making it
very easy to
go get tested a lot of states are like i
probably just have a flu i don't need to
go get tested you may have had covet
nobody knew about it because you didn't
go get tested
in texas you're going to know because at
least you have it available because a
state like texas wants to make it
available for you
but they get shafted every time they do
something like this and they get the
black eye
same thing nationally with the numbers
up if they're so
precautionary in california i mean you
live in california you got a lot of
people there you
obviously your whole family's there why
are they so measured
precautionary rules regulations and they
don't have testing
you know you're saying accessibility how
big is bakersfield can you go to
bakersfield
kai i think the popular function that
ricky lives in 50 i don't know the
bakersfield population what's
bakersfield population
bakersfield population right there
should come up
2020 390 kern county go kern county
kern county k-e-r-n county good luck
spelling that guy ker no he'll get this
current county there you go he's
improving a lot by the way 912.
912 000 that's the 11th largest county
in california almost a million people
and he had to go to glendale to get
covey tested
what the hell are we talking about so is
that a function of california that is
the governor is that a function of
current capital all of it is that i put
it all on california you got a
11th largest county are you making that
difficult for me to get tested
it's 275 a pop that the insurance pays
for right you just go and say i have the
symptoms you take it
insurance pays for the 275 you got
tested how do you not have it in a
county that's the 11th largest county in
california
how do you make it so difficult and the
places you go to guess what they say
we have cova testing but you don't get
the results for 14 days
14 days ridiculous you go to cvs oh we
do i did a covet testing for
cvs i did it twice yeah you know how
long it took for me to get my results 20
minutes cbs no no cvs
17 days oh wow i went to the local
you're a little off there
by the way what do you call these places
what do you call these er
places that they have urgent care no no
you know which ones i'm talking about
you see all over texas
plastic surgery plans i don't know they
have that as well but the er place right
here
three hours just wanna let you know
negative so every time i'm getting
tested because they want me to get
tested regularly you're negative you're
negative three hours
so why is there such a disparency in
three hours in certain places
you wanted three weeks in other places i
don't know i couldn't tell you i
i am not the governor of california i
have no desire to be the governor of
california but they can do things to
improve the testing
and they're not